[Music]
accessing cerebro interface file x-men
history in the beginning there were
humans then evolution took a leap
forward and there's the arrival of Venus
people with unique and special abilities
the presence of Nieman's spread fear
throughout humanity in the 1960s Charles
Xavier a telepath and Erik Lehnsherr a
Holocaust survivor with magnetic
manipulation gathered a group of young
mutants to develop their abilities
together they effectively ended the
comunism crisis however the human race
grew increasingly fearful of Mimas due
to conflicting ideologies of sander and
lunch or partic he's taking with them a
select group of humans it Saviour opened
the school of solution chemistries in
1965 the school operated on the safe
haven for MPS
it is here that Xavier formed the x-men
a group that works to protect humanity
Fletcher codename magneto believe he
needs to be the next stage in evolution
magneto is tMI's extreme and often
violent methods to serve their cause
after several mutant related attacks
tensions reach the breaking Worthington
labs develops a grand solution a mutant
cure which reverted the mutant gene back
into normal human genes an undergrad
lesion Mina's led by magneto attacked
Worthington labs Alcatraz facility
destroying the Golden Gate Bridge and
nearly the entire island before being
stopped
now initiating future scenario campaigns
communities fear of the mutant threat
has grown and Trask industries headed by
Bolivar Trask have led in the crusade to
vent the mutant problem from spreading
the Sentinels bill to seek out and
capture animals historical precedent
dictates that this will be to oppression
and tournament and eventual destruction
creating a world free of meanness heavy
casualties are projected destruction of
several metropolitan areas and a future
scenario interface
[Music]